schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
der deutsche wetterdienst der warnt
aktuell er in einigen regionen
deutschlands vor extremen gewitter
starkregen mit sturm und orkanböen und
angefangen hat es in nordrhein westfalen
über nordrhein-westfalen und wir sehen
dunkle gewitterwolken und noch viel mehr
regen über düsseldorf also da sieht es
wirklich schon ziemlich dunkel aus und
wir hören auch hier donnernden in
einigen regionen kam dann auch wirklich
was runter in mettmann standen straßen
teilweise unter wasser und die behörden
forderten die menschen auf zu hause zu
bleiben so schlimm wie befürchtet wurde
es dort also in nordrhein westfalen
bislang zum glück nicht und das gewitter
zieht nun weiter über teile von
rheinland pfalz und wir können jetzt
auch mal zusammen schauen auf die
aktuelle karte die unwetter karte ich
öffne die mal hier und wir können
gemeinsam schauen wie es aussieht ganz
frisch aktualisiert und jetzt sehen wir
es hier aktuell ganz dunkel lila in
rheinland-pfalz koblenz mayen boppard
also da sieht es aktuell nicht gut aus
wir werden also nun heute in diesem live
über die aktuelle lage sprechen und
möchten euch mitnehmen ihr könnt fragen
stellen die wir dann hier besprechen
können mit einem experten im studio da
kommen wir gleich dazu wir schalten aber
gleich erstmal aktuell in die region die
letztes jahr im juli von einer schweren
flut getroffen wurde und für die
natürlich jetzt solche warnungen gleich
auch noch viel mehr bedeuten denn für
viele menschen dort ist das leben eben
immer noch nicht so wie vorher und wir
schalten zu meiner kollegin zu crystal
haas nach bad neuenahr ahrweiler und
christel wie ist denn jetzt gerade die
situation ich sehe du siehst noch
trocken aus also vielleicht gibt es ja
gerade doch noch gar nicht so schweren
regen
na ja wir haben einen unterstand
gefunden wir stehen hier auf einer
terrasse von einem haus das zumindest
von der flut betroffene ist nicht ganz
zerstört ist es hat vor einer guten
halben stunde hier ein ordentliches
gewitter gegeben aber jetzt im
augenblick hat aufgehört aber es kommt
schon neue dunkle wolken nach und hier
in der stadt gab es zumindest einen
einsatz den die die kräfte leisten
mussten da ist eben die kasse aktion
nicht in ordnung gewesen es ist alles
übergelaufen und dann muss das wasser
jetzt abgepumpt werden es ist natürlich
nicht so schlimm wie vor fast einem jahr
ganz bestimmt nicht aber es ist auch so
dass die kanalisation hier noch gar
nicht richtig in ordnung ist und es
liegt noch ganz viel schutt und ganz
viel dreck und sand herum und wenn es
viel regnet dann ist diese kanalisation
eben sehr schnell überfordert und dann
kann es auch bei weniger starken regen
dazu führen dass die kanäle eben
überlaufen und die strassen überschwemmt
werden und wir hoffen natürlich
insbesondere für diese region das da
also eben nichts schlimmes passiert so
wie das aber letztes jahr der fall war
und du bist gerade vor ort und hat auch
mit menschen gesprochen denn das weckt
natürlich schon auch jede
unwetterwarnung weckt inzwischen
furchtbare erinnerungen wach bei den
menschen richtig
ja da muss nun dollar kommen oder ein
regentropfen fallen und dann löst das
bei vielen einfachen film im kopf aus da
erleben die das noch mal nach was sie
damals erlebt haben und es ist einfach
eine große angst da wir haben mit einer
frau und ihren kindern gesprochen eben
gerade nebenan ist nämlich ein
restaurant das auch geschlossen ist das
auch von der flut betroffen war und die
hat auch gesagt es ist ein ganz
komisches gefühl und natürlich hat man
angst und ich möchte dass meine kinder
eben das nicht mehr erleben und die sie
wollte dann auch gleich nach hause gehen
um eben nicht in diesen regen zu kommen
ganz einfach weil die angst noch da ist
und viele andere schaffen es einfach
noch nicht dass hinter sich zu lassen
denn das hat ja nun irgendwie auch die
leben total verändert zum teil auch
existenzen zerstört und es ist ja auch
so dass der aufbau noch lange nicht
fertig ist und insofern schauen die
leute schon mit großer sorge und mit
bangem blick in den himmel und hoffen
dass es eben nicht so schlimm kommt wie
damals vor knapp einem jahr habe auch
gerade die bilder gesehen aus schuld als
beispiel als du gesprochen hast die
bilder von vor knapp einem jahr und
genau deshalb bedeute neben wir haben
diese schlimme zerstörung gesehen solche
unwetterwarnungen für einige mal enormen
stress nach einem was sie letztes jahr
durchmachen mussten da haben viele
menschen ihr zuhause liebe menschen
verloren und wissen eben ganz genau was
die kraft des wassers anrichten kann
unsere kollegin julia schröter die war
vor ort in der region und hat sich
gefragt oder menschen gefragt wie sie
sich jetzt vorbereiten wenn so eine
unwetterwarnung kommt und vor allem auch
wie es ihnen damit geht wir schauen mal
rein
stoßstange an stoßstange vor dem
betriebshof in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler
war in den letzten tagen der bär los
schlange stehen für ein begehrtes gut
sandsäcke die männer vom ordnungsamt die
aufpassen sind über den antrag nicht
überrascht
und nach der schadenslage die amateur
war ist natürlich klar dass die
befolgung bisschen angst du bist ein
sensibel sind und dass dann schon klar
dass wir einen kombi fahren wollen auf
dem betriebshof angekommen geht alles
wie am schnürchen und nach dem drive im
prinzip zuerst werden die personalien
aufgenommen damit niemand mehrmals
abholt dann kofferraum auf sand
bäckereien jeder privathaushalt bekommt
zehn gewerbetreibende 30 klappe zu
fertig sascha spessart und hier in
skillman haben ebenfalls sandsäcke
geholt auch sie sind freiwillige die
seit monaten im aartal unterstützen
besonders unter ihre fittiche genommen
haben sie eine kneipenwirte die in der
flut vergangenen juli schwer gelitten
hat
die junge frau ist die besitzerin des
ladens die ist schon seit zwei tagen fix
und fertig weil es montag hier auch
nicht so günstig gelaufen ist die ganze
straße aber voll mit wasser hier waren
mehrere löschzüge die ausgepumpt haben
jetzt reden möchte sie nicht zu
schmerzlich immerhin das jetzt sandsäcke
im haus sind ist eine kleine beruhigung
größten für die womöglich nächste flut
dabei sind die traumatischen
erinnerungen an den vergangenen sommer
bei den menschen noch so präsent
es gibt situationen die ich von
betroffenen erzählt bekommen haben die
fahr mit ihrem auto in die waschstraße
reihen der malerischen panikattacken nur
eine waschstraße schon ja dann könnt ihr
euch vorstellen wie es ist wenn sie
jetzt hier wieder wasser auf der straße
steht dann sieht es auch ein bisschen
ganz anders aus robert hugo hat die flut
in bad neuenahr damals vom balkon dieses
hauses aus verfolgt das wasser in der
straße stand mindestens zwei meter hoch
erlebt haben wir es im grunde als
komplettes chaos und nichts neues kam
irgendwas 20 21 uhr kam die
informationen raus 50 meter rechts und
links der wird evakuiert
500 meter sind es nachher geworden und
dann war mitten in der nacht dunkel
und das was er da mit lautem gepolter
und hier kamen die autos land
geschwommen und vorne an der haus und
gestapelt zwei etagen hoch also war
gruselig zurück zum betriebshof in den
letzten tagen haben sie hier tausende
sandsäcke ausgegeben es ist nicht viel
was man selber tun kann aber das wenige
ist immer noch besser als einfach nur
hilflos auf das unwetter zu warten
christel du bist nicht alleine ist für
uns vor ort sondern du stehst dort mit
armin kohl jahns er ist vom asb und er
hat letztes jahr die flut live
mitbekommen und weiß wahrscheinlich ganz
genau wie sich die menschen in der
region gerade für
richtig genormt herculis sie wissen eben
ganz genau was da passiert ist letztes
jahr und dass das eben auch was macht
mit menschen die sich jetzt einfach auch
fürchten wenn da unwetterwarnungen
rauskommen wie beschreiben sie uns ein
bisschen wäre ja was sie was sie
anbieten vielleicht auch für all jene
die das enorme unter stress setzt
wir haben verschiedene projekte an
sieben standorten haben wir insgesamt
165 behelfsunterkünfte und
beziehungsweise wohneinheiten aufgebaut
wo menschen die ihre häuser ihre wohnung
verloren haben jetzt ein zuhause
gefunden haben und anfang der woche war
schon mal ein starkregens letzte mal hat
es ja in der april geregnet und dann
jetzt am montag nochmal ganz viel das
boden konnte das nicht aufnehmen die
kanalisation es immer noch nicht
hundertprozentig in ordnung so dass es
für die menschen ein besonderes ereignis
war dass das wasser von den standort
lich gut abfließen konnte das hat
natürlich auch wenn den menschen was
ausgelöst bei den bewohnern gerade bei
den kindern und da haben wir mit ja
sozialbetreuer welchen maßnahmen in
kontakt gestanden die menschen
unterstützt und waren für die leute doch
wie kann man sich das genau vorstellen
also ich besitz zu hause nicht für mich
nicht wohl kann ich dann anrufen oder
gibt es orte wo ich hingehen kann wie
life das genau
wir haben eine telefonnummer
aufgeschaltet so oder so 24 stunden sind
wir erreichbar besonderen situationen
wenn jemand redebedarf hat wenn jemand
unterstützung braucht oder bei
technischen defekten zimmer auf jeden
fall erreichbar
jetzt aktuell wurden wir gestern von der
stadt bad neuenahr angesprochen ob wir
nicht drei anlaufstellen betreiben
könnten eine vierte betreuung noch
betrieben wo menschen niedrigschwelligen
angeboten zu uns kommen können und
einfach jeder bedarf haben wenn sie sich
zu hause unwohl fühlen wenn es regnet
beziehe man vielleicht nicht zu hause
ist und die mutter mit zwei oder drei
kindern nicht alleine zu hause sein
möchte in der situation
so dass die menschen einfach im gespräch
stehen können dass im zweifel auch die
kinder betreut werden können von uns vom
asb oder dass man einfach bei kaffee und
kuchen bei sandes und das hat nicht
alleine durchstehen muss wir sind auf
jeden fall für die menschen da uns genau
agieren hier nach bedarf gewiss benötigt
wird wir haben einen kommentar bei
youtube von mp pommes 96 er oder sie
schreibt ich hoffe dass das urteil
dieses mal verschont bleibt ich war
bereits oft da zum helfen und das wäre
einfach ein schlag ins gesicht für alle
helfer sollte es wieder zu einer
überflutung kommen sie haben das ja auch
live mitbekommen waren also letztes jahr
live vor ort ansprechpartner wie geht es
ihnen tatsächlich jetzt damit haben sie
selbst auch sorge oder hat sich das in
grenzen
tatsächlich sieht das 30 kilometer ganz
anders aus da sind die menschen nicht so
affektiert von der situation haben die
flut oder die situation so nicht
miterlebt wie die menschen hier vor ort
das sind jetzt starke regenfälle lösen
hat natürlich wurde menschen was aus
aber auch da steckt man nicht drin wenn
dann noch mal so viel regen kommen
sollte dann wissen wir
da gibt es keine physikalischen
hemmungen noch davor wie zum beispiel
brücken oder baumstämme die vielleicht
angespült werden also so eine situation
wie letztes jahr ist nach meiner
einschätzung vielleicht eher
unwahrscheinlich aber jetzt gerade eine
situation bei den starken regen vom
montag von gestern und von heute muss
man aber auch ganz klar sagen mit 50
litern pro quadratmeter
da merkt man schon dass die
kanalisationen etwas überfordert ist
aber das ist jenseits von einer
tatsächlichen physikalischen gefahr für
die menschen ist er die emotionale
bindung oder die psychische belastung
dadurch dass es noch nicht mal ein jahr
her ist und jetzt regnet es wieder ganz
stark in behelfsunterkünften an die
wende nicht so fest bedeckt wie ein
stein gebauten haus und da kann ich das
nicht schon verstehen dass da halt aber
dorf gibt und da unterstützen wir dann
auch gut zu wissen dass sie da also
vorbereitet sind und den menschen da
auch eine stütze sind vielen dank herr
kilian wenn sie noch einmal an christel
haas übergeben können dann können wir
mit ihr nämlich noch einmal darüber
sprechen wie also jetzt auch die
situation gerade in puncto wiederaufbau
ist der aktuelle stand christel denn
nicht alles ist jetzt ein jahr später
wieder hergestellt du hast es
angesprochen am anfang gerade auch in
sachen organisation da funktioniert also
alles noch nicht so richtig was sind die
schwierigkeiten da gerade auch dass sich
natürlich alles wieder zurück zu einem
normalen zustand bewegen könnte
erst dauert alles halt sehr lange und
wenn man wiederaufbau hilfe beantragen
will weil man keine versicherung hat
dann ist das sehr komplizierte sind
mehrere seiten die akribisch ausgefüllt
werden müssen und die dann eingeschickt
werden müssen und wenn irgendwas nicht
richtig ausgefüllt ist dann kommt das
zurück und wird nicht bearbeitet und das
eben für viele leute einfach ganz
stressig weil weil das auch kompliziert
ist eine herausforderung ist vor allen
dingen auch für ältere leute diesen
bogen oder diesen fragebogen korrekt
auszufüllen und dann muss man natürlich
warten dass es genehmigt ist und erst
wenn man die genehmigung hat dann kann
man auch ein handwerker bestellen weil
man dann eben ein abschlag von 20% des
des betrags bekommt und damit kann man
arbeiten weil viele leute haben ja jetzt
nicht unbedingt das große geld um ihre
wohnungen wieder aufzubauen sind
angewiesen auf diese wiederaufbauhilfe
und dann kommt ein weiteres problem
hinzu dass nämlich die handwerker auch
völlig überlastet sind weil überall muss
wieder aufgebaut werden überall muss
geholfen werden die kommen mittlerweile
aus dem gesamten bundesgebiet und
trotzdem sind es nicht genug und dazu
kommt noch und das macht es noch
schwieriger
das mittlerweile auch die baumaterialien
fehlen und auch die preise durch die
ukraine krise immer höher werden die
erhöhen sich wöchentlich so dass die
handwerksbetriebe auch immer weiter ihre
angebote erneuern oder updaten müssen
weil eben einfach die preise so
unterschiedlich sind und das verzögert
eben alles und das liegt natürlich den
menschen die die eigentlich schnell
wieder in die normalität zurückkommen
wollen sehr auf der seele und
das ist halt die schwierigkeit zum
schluss noch die frage hier bei uns aus
dem stream christel der fragt sich reif
dominik bei facebook die politik hat
doch sicher vorkehrungen getroffen falls
noch mal eine flut kommt oder
ja man ist zumindest dabei ein neues
neuen schutzmechanismus zu besprechen
und maßnahmen zu ergreifen damit das
eben nicht nicht vorkommt aber noch ist
das nicht in trockenen tüchern noch gibt
es da nichts konkretes bis dahin
arbeitet man weiß dass die zeit
davonläuft und das ist schnell passieren
muss es gibt zusätzlich ein problem und
das kann man wirklich nicht lösen es
gibt das fragen auch viele es gibt
häuser die da wieder aufgebaut werden wo
sie eben zerstört worden sind und die
sind eben in diesem
überflutungsgebiet für den fall dass es
eine neue flut gibt und dann fragen
natürlich viele warum werden die häuser
denn da wieder aufgebaut aber das hat
einen ganz konkreten grund denn wenn man
irgendwo anders sein haus wieder
aufbauen möchte dann braucht man nicht
baugenehmigung man braucht einen platz
und dann würde man auch keine
wiederaufbauhilfe bekommen und so sagen
viele eben in dieser situation dann
nehmen wir die wiederaufbauhilfe und
bauen unser haus dort auf wo es ist
selbst wenn es vielleicht gefährdet ist
bevor wir gar nichts mehr haben vielen
dank für die einschätzung von vor ort an
crystal harris und auch ein armin korans
dem ihr zuvor gehört haben vom asb
dankeschön
sehr gerne
und wir können jetzt im studio noch ein
bisschen hintergründiger tiefgründiger
sprechen ich bin hier nämlich nicht
alleine sondern ich bin mit unserem
wetterexperten hier zusammen im studio
mit dem meteorologen assistent ally
schön dass du da bist du ja danke für
die einladung ich habe gerade schon den
ernten kommentar nämlich gesehen er
passt sehr gut zu dem gespräch mit dir
und zwar schreibt hier haider celica ich
hoffe ich habe das richtig ausgesprochen
bei youtube menschen müssen einsehen
dass es bald immer mehr orte geben wird
die unbewohnbar für menschen werden also
gleich wird er jetzt mal auf das große
ganze geguckt hashtag klimawandel jetzt
müssen wir natürlich vielleicht erst mal
klären ist das jetzt einfach nur wetter
und unwetter ganz normal für die zeit
oder hat das was mit klimawandel zu tun
na ja also das ist ja immer diese fragen
der ich antworte man darauf man kann den
klimawandel oder klimakrise man kann das
nicht ein und ausschalten wir haben dass
er permanent um uns herum sie haben ja
die atmosphäre entsprechend verändert
dass sie halt auch heftiger wirkt
beziehungsweise die klimakrise die
klimafolgen die wirken aufs wetter und
wenn man sich anschaut wie es zum
beispiel in spanien heute warte ein paar
tun um 40 grad oder in frankreich der
wird wahrscheinlich der mai ein
absoluter ausnahme mai werden zu trocken
und zu warm da werden rekorde purzeln
und diese hitze die hat auch mit uns zu
tun handy die quasi in spanien und
frankreich aufkam die wurde von
nordafrika hingeführt und das lag eben
auch daran ist die strömungen
entsprechend waren das quasi die wärme
von süden nach norden transportiert
wurde das haben wir ja auch bekommen und
wir haben mai also im mai temperaturen
um 33 grad ich habe jetzt den letzten
temperatur nicht gecheckt aber das war
im südwesten heute richtig heiß
eigentlich wie im juni oder im juli und
das war jetzt auch neben den letzten
tagen so dass wir jetzt nicht mal eine
kurze phase sondern sondern richtige
hitze und ja klar und dann wird diese
hitze irgendwann auch ausgeräumt dazu
kamen diese feuchtigkeit und dann die
kalte luft aus dem norden und mit diesen
zutaten insgesamt hat sich eben dieses
tief gebildet und es bildet sich ja noch
weiter ist zieht ja allmählich nach
osten und wird auch weiter heftig sein
also ich muss sagen wenn man sagt
klimakrise und wetter da das spielt
einfach immer eine rolle das ist immer
irgendwie verknüpft und nicht mehr
trennbar wir leben in der klimakrise
aber bezogen auf dieses ereignis jetzt
auf dieses tief die es dessen
auswirkungen das ist natürlich sehr sehr
heftig dass es außergewöhnlich dass
solche zutaten dann da sind sage ich mal
also die luftfeuchtigkeit die hitze und
dann auch die kalte luft die da ein
strömt und dass dieses tief sich quasi
auch über uns er allmählich entwickelt
normalerweise haben wir das so dass die
tiefe aus dem westen zu uns kommen über
uns hinweg rauschen und weg sind sie und
dieses bildet sich tatsächlich über
deutschland auch gerade jetzt und es
wirkt auch noch weiter bis heute abend
und bis morgen früh noch das selbst
meine nächste frage wenn wir ganz
aktuell auf die situation für die
menschen jetzt in rheinland-pfalz gucken
muss gerade überzieht heißt es jetzt
schon entwarnung oder ist das eben noch
ein bisschen angespannt also schauer
wird es dann noch geben aber danach wird
es ein wenig ruhiger ich habe eben auch
noch gerade geschaut sieht nach an der
luftdruck steigt dann wieder und es wird
ruhiger werden als erstes sogar im
westen völlig andere situationen dann
nach norden hin hier können wir auf das
radarbild schauen wir haben nämlich 1
und da sehen wir auch ich muss mal
gucken wo haben wir es vielleicht bilden
blenden
als auch gern mal durchlaufen lassen und
da sehen wir ja die entwicklung von
heute und ja was da quasi auch in bonn
und südlich also quasi richtungen aartal
auch ist ja da kommt also noch schauer
und gewitter auf wenn das aber abgezogen
ist dann in der nacht wird es dort
ruhiger aber ganz anders dieser flaschen
sage ich mal nach norden hin das ist
unser unwetter tief was man hier erkennt
und das zieht in die mitte und dann
weiter nach osten wird berlin erreichen
wird teilweise dann auch
thüringen sachsen und dann nach süden
hin dann sich auch weiter ausweiten also
nicht dieses zentrum aber man sieht ja
da schon dieser arme die im süden sind
die bringen dann auch weiter heftige
schauer und gewitter im teils extreme
unwetter bereich was sie jetzt da sehen
ist es tief was sie entwickelt hat ich
gucke da gerade auch mal mit drauf auf
den monitor genau und da ist es jetzt
über der mitte und zieht weiter in den
osten zieht raus man sieht aber im süden
deutschlands da wird es auch weiter
regen bis in die früh stunden also das
ganze ist auch danach nicht ganz durch
aber es schwächt sich durchaus ab und
wir haben kann auch mal hier gleich auf
meinen wette ich ziehe das auseinander
so gerne auf meinen laptop schalten und
da sehen wir nämlich auch diese unwetter
genau
dieses violette das sind die extremen
unwetter also extreme unwetter gibt es
nun nicht so häufig na und wenn es sie
gibt dann gibt es auch ein grund dafür
hier böen bis 140 kilometer pro stunde
sind möglich dass es im bereich des
möglichen 540 liter pro stunde auf den
quadratmeter und großer hagerer um vier
zentimeter davor wird jetzt zum beispiel
nach osten hin gewarnt und auch im
westen gibt es diese lieder flächen das
rote dass er die unwetter bereiche wo es
eben auch etwas nicht ganz so heftige
auswirkungen gibt aber wir müssen
weiterhin im norden und zum nach osten
zum beispiel in berlin schauen uns mal
an was der deutsche wetterdienst da noch
also das sind jetzt die die vorab
informationen und da das tief nun dahin
zieht müssen wir halt auch weiter nimmt
rechnen also wir können nicht sagen wir
geben jetzt entwarnung oder es ist auch
schwierig mit diesen in dieser situation
zu sagen das war es jetzt und also wir
wissen mit diesen zutaten noch nicht
dass es durch ist und wir können das
auch nicht sagen also da steckt noch
eine menge musik hinter stichwort habe
ich habe dirk wehrmann tweet geschickt
du bist eine nachricht von mir begangen
haben dann können wir den tweet nämlich
vielleicht mal aufrufen wir haben ja
gerade hier mit dem laptop verkabelt
falls der moment ich muss noch jedes mal
ich sag bescheid wann genau das ist
nämlich tatsächlich durchaus
angesprochen habe und den habe ich
gerade gesehen bei twitter er hat sabine
maurer hast sie gepostet fünf zentimeter
große hagelkörner in neue bieter
anlocken und ja vielleicht schauen wir
noch mal auf deinen laptop mal sehen was
ne also
ja das ist extrem und ich muss auch
sagen es gibt einen tornado verdacht
also davor haben wir ja auch gewarnt und
das war auch in den daten drin ich habe
es auch auf einem also auf dem radarbild
konnte man erkennen wie sich das da es
quasi ein drehte das war schon zu
erwarten
und ja das muss halt bestätigt werden ob
es tatsächlich ein tornado war aber ich
denke dass das ganze ist noch nicht
durch und wie gesagt das ding sieht ja
erst in der nacht nach osten hin raus
und vorher sind da noch großstädte wie
berlin dresden und da muss man mal
schauen wie sich das noch weiter
entwickelt und warum ist das manchmal so
schwer vorherzusagen wo es besonders
schlimm wird das hat ja eben auch
letztes jahr zur flut so viele menschen
so überrascht dass das so heftig werden
könnte warum ist es so schwer also der
unterschied zum zu letztes jahr war das
war ziemlich gut vorher gesagt also es
war ja so dass ja sogar die regenmenge
in etwa gestimmt haben oder dass es
flächendeckend so große regenmengen gab
dass es diese überflutungen gegeben hat
also kurz
kleinräumigen gewittern ist das
schwierig weil die puppen quasi wie
popcorn in der pfanne nach oben also
wenn man auf einen satelliten film guckt
und dann das quasi so durchlaufen lässt
sich das tatsächlich so aussieht knallt
dann so überall hoch und das ist dann
sehr lokal ich kann dieses einzelne
gewitter kann ich dir nicht vorhersagen
aber ich kann hier in der region quasi
nennen wo diese gewitter entstehen und
letztendlich macht der deutsche
wetterdienst ja nichts anderes dem er
diese bereiche straff diese wo das
extreme wetter sein kann ja und wir
sehen ja zum teil passiert das ja auch
und das sind ja hier also diesen hagel
wenn man den abkriegt ich glaube das tut
ziemlich weh und du hast eben auch noch
was interessantes angesprochen gefahr
für einzelne tornados klingt irgendwie
für deutschland verrückt wäre näher an
die usa wenn man ja wie entsteht denn so
war es also auch gerade vielleicht hier
bei uns wie kann das sein also die
hauptzutat ist natürlich man brauchte
erst einmal so ein gewitter also
meistens dann eher eine super celle ein
super zelle ist ein gewitter was
komplett rotiert ja das ist also
wirklich ein sehr brachiales teil sehr
hoch reichend und unter diesem unter
dieser super zelle kann sich eben einen
einfall bilden wenn du so lange als den
boden nicht berührt ist das kein tornado
nennt man es wandel aber wenn es den
boden berührt hat nennt man es toll was
braucht man dafür erst mal diese super
zelle und die super zelle rotiert weil
unterschiedliche windrichtungen mit der
höhe sind und das ist in diesem fall
auch gegeben also derzeit mit dem tief
und dadurch wissen wir dass tornados
möglich sind aber hier ist es noch viel
schwieriger zu sagen hier und da wird es
ein tornado geben man kann dann auch nur
sehr
vereinzelt dann in eine richtung schauen
und sagen er im norden deutschlands also
im süden weil eben die witterung so
nennt man das eben wenn die wind wenn
der wind aus unterschiedlichen
richtungen kommt
wenn das gegeben ist dann ist das
durchaus möglich und mehr kann man da
auch nicht sagen also ich kann ihr weder
anzahl sagen doch wo die auftreten
werden also nur eine region und du hast
gesagt habe ich nicht verstanden dass
man eigentlich wetter und klima wandel
das gehört inzwischen zusammen kann man
gar nicht mehr so richtig trennen und
wenn ich mich jetzt auch immer an den
kommentar am anfang von unserem gespräch
als jemand vermutet hat es gibt
vielleicht irgendwann regionen wo keiner
mehr leben will oder kann und wer mir so
ein vorgeschmack gekriegt letztes jahr
also wirklich regionen wo niemand
mitgerechnet hat die also für einen
moment bis heute teilweise
schwierigkeiten haben bewohnbar zu sein
glaubst du dass das etwas ist befürchtet
um womit wir uns in der zukunft noch
mehr auseinander setzen muss also ich
würde sagen in deutschland ist es nicht
so weit wie in anderen ländern aber
mittelmeer zum beispiel wenn die
temperaturen immer weiter steigen
bekommen ja auch zum beispiel in so
einer situation wie jetzt teilweise aus
nordafrika teilweise aus dem
mittelmeerraum bekommen wir ja diese
heiße luft ja was passiert denn wenn es
dort immer heißer wird also es wird auch
in deutschland immer wärmer in
mitteleuropa war dort nehmen die
temperaturen dann deutlich stärker zu
und es wird dann heißer sein was wird
dann dasein klar es wird wenn wir so
wenn wir da einfach so weitermachen
business as usual also kein klimaschutz
betreiben nicht das co2 aus der
atmosphäre
nicht begrenzen dass es halt nicht mehr
wird dann setzt sich das fort war dass
sie im physik ist ja dass co2 ist nun
mal die ursache dass zusätzliche was wir
aus stoßen ist normal die ursache für
die erwärmung und für die ganzen
veränderungen auf unserem planeten die
ja viel weitreichender sind als nur ich
sag jetzt nur der klimawandel hier
zerstören ja ganz schön viel ist ein
anderes thema aber das spielt alles
ineinander weil das ist ja alles
miteinander verbunden ab montag so habe
ich es gelesen droht uns aber
tatsächlich schon die nächste gewinner
lage geht es jetzt so weiter über den
sommer gibt es im moment die richtigen
zutaten dafür dass das jetzt noch öfter
auftritt also montag bekommen wir wieder
so ne warm luftblase quasi und dann
entwickeln sich diese heftigen gewitter
die dann auch wieder im unwetter bereich
liegen werden wahrscheinlich und es gibt
es interessante hast du fragst weil vom
deutschen wetterdienst gibt es eine
projektion das für juni juli und august
die temperaturabweichung für drei monate
also über drei monate hinweg etwa bei 2
grad in großen teilen deutschlands liegt
das klingt jetzt nicht viel aber über so
einen langen zeitraum so eine hohe
abweichungen also das ist quasi wärmer
ist als normal ist ist sehr viel
und das
könnte verschiedene ursachen aber kann
leider das nicht genauer eingrenzen was
für ein wetter dahinter steckt aber
offenbar bekommen wir deutlich wärmere
luft in den nächsten monaten ab als was
eigentlich üblich wäre für unsere für
unseren sommer in deutschland zum
schluss noch ist denn es ist so dass
unsere redaktion jetzt ja auch gefallen
gefunden hat die wie die idee ich sehe
schon videos zu schicken und zwar so
dass tornado videos
wenn wir die uns noch mal anschauen ob
das jetzt wirklich einer ist oder nicht
ich schaue gleichwertig wird gleich ich
sagt man hier drauf halten könnt ja
langsam rein ob da also tatsächlich
jetzt ein tornado zu sehen ist oder
nicht aber als jetzt jeder mitgekriegt
hat dass ich dir
recht
eindeutige rotation zu erkennen ich weiß
ja mal kann ich jetzt natürlich nicht
weder bestätigen dass das also nichts
gegen irgendjemanden der das gepostet
hat wieder dass das jetzt echt ist also
es ist echt was da passiert aber ob das
aktuell ist kann ich jetzt natürlich
nicht sagen aber wenn ich das nur
bewährte was ich da sehe ist eindeutig
eine rotation zu erkennen das ist kein
kein wolken größe in dem sinne zu sehen
aber
war doch hier tut sich irgendwas in dem
bereich schwierig ist es das ist ja
diffus
marken rüssel sagen wir noch mal was ja
der also wort noch so wie du es da sieht
man jetzt schon neumann man sieht dass
nicht das ist es was aus der wolke
heraus wächst wie du es kannst aus den
usa diese riesigen diese rüssel die sich
unter der wolke drehen quasi und da wo
sie den boden berühren da passiert da
sehr so ähnlich wie das jetzt hier im
video zu sehen uns fliegt alles so umher
aber dass die sind dann noch viel
krasser wobei auch hier in deutschland
wirklich krasse tornados möglich sind
und es gibt ja 50 bis 60 tornados also
im schnitt sagt man in deutschland auch
und sie werden ja oft auch gesichtet
mittlerweile hat ja jeder ein handy und
kann einfach draufhalten es scheint ein
paar videos dieser zugeben dass nächstes
jahr in bern felix sommer aber du sagst
natürlich richtig ist denn wir wissen
jetzt nicht genau das ist ja immer ein
bisschen die krux ist das video
tatsächlich von jetzt von heute aus
diesem moment da ist man immer gut
beraten egal um was es sich haben wir
das mal nachgeguckt ist es auf jeden
fall aus der korona zeit wir zeigen euch
gleich mal weil ich sehe einen papp
aufsteller testcenter gut möglich eben
dass das heute von heute ist aber wir
wollen da jetzt vielleicht auch gar
nicht weiter mutmaßen mit sollen euch ja
eigentlich immer zeigen videos von denen
wir bestätigt wissen dass sie also von
heute sind aber ich glaube ich schon
noch mal in die kommentare ob von euch
noch offene fragen sind ich glaube du
hast uns nämlich schon richtig viel
heute beantwortet nicht nur zum
aktuellen unwetter sondern dann lasst
uns auch gleich die einordnung gegeben
was gerade so los ist europäisch in
sachen klimawandel ich glaube das war
spannend für uns alle vielen dank
jeannine unser wetter experte und danke
euch für kommentare videos und dass er
zugeschaut habe passt alle natürlich
auch wo immer ihr seid wir haben es ja
gehört das unwetter zieht noch über
deutschland und deswegen dass man da
selbstschutz so habe ich heute von einem
feuerwehrmann mit dem ich telefoniert
habe gehört dass selbstschutz natürlich
immer das wichtigste ist dass man gut
auf sich aufpasst und sich nicht in
gefahr begibt darauf sollten wir alle
achten deswegen bis dahin passt auf euch
auf und schießt